We have previously defined
the abstract conditional
expectation of one random
variable given
another random variable.
And we discussed that it is, by
itself, a random variable.
In particular, it has
an expectation, or
mean, of its own.
What is this mean?
This is what we want
to find out.
Let us recall our development.
We look at the conditional
expectation of a random
variable given a specific
numerical value of another
random variable.
This is a number that
depends on little y.
And this can be used to define
a function little g.
The function little g for any
particular little y tells us
the numerical value of the
conditional expectation.
Since little g is a well defined
function, we can also
now define this particular
function, which is now a
function of a random variable.
It's a well defined object.
It's a random variable.
And then we introduced this
abstract notation.
We defined this object
to be exactly this
particular random variable.
So now we want to calculate
the expected value of this
object, which is written
this way.
Now this notation, here, may
look quite formidable, but
let's see what is happening.
Inside here, we have
a random variable.
And we take the expected value
of that random variable.
Or, more crisply, think of that
as the expected value of
g of capital Y, where g of
capital Y is defined through
these correspondences here.
How do we calculate the expected
value of a function
of a random variable?
Here we use the Expected
Value Rule.
Assuming that Y is a discrete
random variable, the Expected
Value Rule takes this form.
And the next step is to
substitute the particular form
for g of Y that we have.
g of Y was defined
in this manner.
So we're dealing with the sum
over all little y's of the
expected value of X, given that
Y takes the value little
y, weighted by the
PMF of little y.
Now if we look at this
expression, then it should
look familiar.
It is the expression that
appears in the Total
Expectation Theorem.
We take the conditional
expectation under different
scenarios and weigh those
conditional expectations
according to the probabilities
of those scenarios.
And this just gives us the
overall expectation of the
random variable X.
So this step, here, was carried
out using the Total
Expectation Theorem.
So we have proved this important
fact, that the
expectation of a conditional
expectation is the same as the
unconditional expectation.
This important fact is called
the Law of Iterated
Expectations.
The proof was carried out
assuming that Y is discrete.
So we use this particular
version involving a PMF, but
the proof is exactly the same
for the continuous case.
You would be using an integral
and the PDF, instead the PMF.
As the proof indicates, the Law
of Iterated Expectations
is nothing but an abstract
version of the Total
Expectation Theorem.
It is really the Total
Expectation Theorem written in
more abstract notation.
But this turns out to be
powerful and also we avoid
having to deal separately
with discrete or
continuous random variables.